[Musik]
mal ehrlich wer hat nicht schon
mindestens einmal in seinem leben eine
tasse kaffee getrunken ich bin mir sogar
ziemlich sicher dass viele von euch
dieses produkt täglich genießen und dann
gibt es natürlich noch leute die den
ganzen tag süchtig nach diesem
angenehmen und belebende getränk sind
oder zumindest so wie ich ihre tat erst
mal mit einer tasse des duftenden
wachmacher beginnen müssen so wie
diesmal auch dieses video kannst du dir
vorstellen ohne einen frischen kaffee in
den tag zu starten kaffee ist zu einem
dieser globalen produkte geworden wie
man praktisch in jedem winkel der welt
finden kann aber hast du dich nicht auch
schon mal gefragt was ich eigentlich
hinter der dampfenden tasse eines
koffein getrickst verbirgt nun um genau
diese frage zu beantworten haben wir
dieses video gedreht wir werden hier
alle wichtigen details und
herausforderungen dieser spannenden
branche verraten ihre wichtigsten
charakteristika und geheimnisse denn wir
haben es mit einem markt zu tun über den
merkwürdigerweise nicht viel gesprochen
wird obwohl er gemessen am volumen der
wirtschaftlichen transaktionen einer der
größten der weltwirtschaft ist und er
wächst noch weiter denn es wird global
immer mehr und mehr kaffee konsumiert
wie du siehst reden hier keineswegs über
eine kleine industrie im jahr 2020
wurden im kaffeegeschäft mehr als 450
milliarden dollar umgesetzt dies
entspricht etwa der größe der globalen
illegalen drogen industrie welche dieses
umsatzvolumen allerdings mit einer
ganzen palette von drogen zusammen
bekommt heute widmen wir uns jedoch nur
einem einzigen produkt dem psychotropen
extrakt der gerösteten bohnen der
kaffeepflanze also bist du bereit in die
spannende welt deines morgen getränks
einzutauchen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
von allen großen globalen industrien mit
deren produkten wir täglich in kontakt
kommen ist die kaffeebranche
interessanterweise jene über die
vielleicht am wenigsten in der
öffentlichkeit bekannt ist dass sie sehr
viel kaffee aus lateinamerika kommt ist
zwar wohl bekannt und ja 70 prozent der
weltweiten kaffeebohnen produktion kommt
von dort aber die sechs größten
produktionsländer der welt sind folgende
brasilien vietnam kolumbien indonesien
und duras und äthiopien du siehst also
asien und afrika sind auch stark in der
produktion unter den top ten finden wir
dann auch per optionaler und mexiko okay
soweit eigentlich keine größeren
überraschungen nicht wahr es handelt
sich ausnahmslos um einkommensschwache
länder in denen es viel armut gibt vor
allem auf dem land dort wo der kaffee
angebaut wird aber schauen wir uns jetzt
mal eine andere liste an die der größten
kaffee exporteure dh welche länder
verdienen mit dem café das meiste geld
und da tauchen in der top 6 neben
brasilien kolumbien und vietnam auch die
schweiz deutschland und italien auf
fällt dir was auf genau auf dem globalen
kaffeemarkt sind die größten produzenten
nicht immer diejenigen die auch das
meiste geld mit dem café handel
verdienen und das trotz der tatsache
dass kaffee ganz bestimmte klimatische
bedingungen braucht eine bestimmte art
von bodentemperatur
niederschlagsintensität und höhe über
dem meeresspiegel
mit anderen worten kaffee dort nur dort
angebaut wo kaffee angebaut werden kann
was den produzenten ja eigentlich eine
gewisse marktmacht geben sollte aber
natürlich könnten wir zur
veranschaulichung anbringen dass die
packung kaffee die wir in einen
supermarkt kaufen so etwas wie das
äquivalent eines baumwoll t shirts in
einem bekleidungsgeschäft ist während
der in kolumbien geerntete café der
frisch gepflügten baumwolle gleichkommt
denn natürlich gibt es für beide
produkte einen intensiven prozess der
transformation und wertschöpfung
außerdem kommt auf dem weg dorthin doch
das marketing hinzu wir werden später
sehen warum das wichtig ist zuerst aber
wollte uns den fall der schweiz ansehen
die kleine schweiz schöpft aus dem café
export die zweithöchsten einnahmen der
welt fast drei milliarden dollar trotz
der tatsache dass in dem alten land
keine einzige kaffeeplantage gilt
übertreffen die kaffee exporte sogar die
von kolumbien das sagt viel aus vor
allem wenn man bedenkt dass in dem
lateinamerikanischen land mehr als
700.000 menschen in diesem sektor
arbeiten und das land jedes jahr mehr
als 14 millionen kaffeebohnen 630 5 bzw
60 kilo produziert diese säcke sind eine
art standardmaßen für kaffee so wie es
das barrel für erdöl ist nun der punkt
ist als die schweiz umgerüsteten café
importiert also die wohnen wie sie vom
feld kommen wohnen die dann gerüstet
verpackt und auf vielerlei verschiedene
arten verkauft werden und genau dabei
bei der umwandlung dieses produkt in ein
endprodukt wird jener wert geschaffen
der den preis des kaffees vervielfacht
die schweizer haben diesen prozess
perfektioniert und herrschen die
dahinter liegenden marktmechanismen nun
mal aus dem effeff und das ist der grund
warum das landes so viel geschäft mit
dem export von kaffee macht ohne selbst
über kaffeeplantagen zu verfügen
unternehmen wie nestlé dass der
drittgrößte private innbrücke von kaffee
ist verwandeln die einfache bohne aus
brasilien zum beispiel produkte die im
alltag der entwickelten länder so
alltäglich sind wie espresso kapseln
[Musik]
und das ist der schlüsselfaktor der
kaffee zu einem so lukrativen geschäft
macht es erklärt warum die kaffeebauern
in vielen fällen nicht einmal ein
hundertstel des preises sehen zu denen
ihre produktion schließlich an den
verbraucher verkauft wird
[Musik]
tja die welt ist eben fahrt ungerecht
und mit jeder kapsel die du in deiner
kapselmaschine steckst wird sie noch ein
bisschen härter und ungerechter ist doch
so oder nun wie ihr wisst sind wir hier
bei visual politik keine fans platter
weltbilder und vorurteile bevor wir also
damit anfangen die bösen kapitalisten
weil sie die bauern auspressen an den
pranger zu stellen lasst uns die
zusammenhänge aufschlüsseln die genaue
erklärung für diese situation ergründen
denn die wahrheit ist das alles eine
erklärung hat und hinter der erklärung
verbergen sich auch mögliche lösungen
und sind ist nicht eben lösungen die uns
am meisten interessieren also lange rede
kurzer sinn inwiefern profitieren die
produktionsländer vom enormen globalen
kaffeegeschäft die hat es die schweiz
überhaupt geschafft einen kaffee sektor
aufzubauen der vom umsatz her größer ist
als der kolumbiens all das werden wir in
diesem video beantworten lasst uns nun
also die spannende frage klären wie ist
denn die schweiz geschafft hat eine
kaffee industrie aufzubauen die mehr
umsatz macht als die kolumbiens
aufgepasst
[Musik]
die fußabdrücke des cafés
die kaffeeindustrie hat sich in den
letzten jahrzehnten verändern von
kapseln über automaten bis zu starbucks
die kaffeeindustrie verändert sich
ständig und es scheint dass das erlebnis
immer mehr erzählt und mittlerweile
wichtiger ist dass lebensmittel an sich
was sich jedoch nicht so sehr verändert
hat ist die situation in den wichtigsten
anbauländern zumindest nicht was diesen
rohstoff betrifft
[Musik]
kaffeeanbau region sind in vielen fällen
immer noch ein synonym für
unterentwickelte regionen
konkret geht es um rund 25 millionen
kleine kraft die produzenten von denen
80 prozent unter der armutsgrenze leben
eine milliardenschwere industrie die auf
absolute armut aufbaut in kolumbien zum
beispiel in einem land das kaffeebohnen
aus allen rohren ballert macht der
export gerade einmal 0,7 prozent seiner
wirtschaft aus und in brasilien den
größten produzenten der welt nur 0,3
prozent
mit anderen worten kaffee ist für die
schweizer wirtschaft lukrativer als für
kolumbien einfach verrückt doch damit
stellt sich die frage was ist hier
eigentlich los welche probleme haben die
produzierenden länder warum sind länder
wie kolumbien und du raus oder brasilien
nicht in der lage diese enorme quelle
des reichtums auszubeuten nun wir können
hauptsächlich drei großen hindernisse
hervorheben zum einen wäre da die größe
der produzent zwischen 70 und 80 prozent
des weltweit produzierten cafés wird von
kleinbauern auf kleinen fahnen kleinen
plantagen reduziert und das was auf den
ersten blick für viele von euch wie eine
irrelevante tatsache erscheinen marke
und für andere sogar ein szenario das
aktivismus und sozialromantik
heraufbeschwört jene kleinbauern die mit
ihren eigenen händen werte schaffen
indem sie morgens mittags und abends die
felder bearbeiten ist nichts geringeres
als die lösung des rätsels warum kaffee
für die schweiz so viel lukrativer ist
als für kolumbien
[Musik]
denn die überwiegende mehrheit dieser 25
millionen kleinen kaffeeproduzenten und
befindet sich in ländlichen und
verarmten gebieten von ländern die
ohnehin schon sehr arm sind mit anderen
worten besprechen von produzenten die
nicht über ausreichende wirtschaftliche
mittel verfügen um investitionsgüter zu
investieren wie zum beispiel traktoren
mit denen sie die produktivität ihrer
plantagen verbessern können oder um
komplexere geschäftsmodelle zu
entwickeln
wir haben es hier mit einem
ausgewachsenen teufelskreis zu tun ohne
ausreichende mittel können sie sich
nicht weiterentwickeln und weiß sie sich
nicht weiterentwickeln haben sie nicht
die mittel um ihren lebensstandard zu
verbessern aus dem tal herauskommen und
sich von den gut organisierten café
händlern unabhängiger zu machen und hier
finden wir das zweite große problem der
kleinen café bauer wenn einer oder
mehrere dieser bauern eine eigene
kaffeerösterei und verarbeitung aufbauen
wollten bräuchten sie riesige summen an
geld das heißt sie müssten einen kredit
aufnehmen oder ein investor finden in
diesen ländern sind die finanzmärkte
jedoch stark unterentwickelt so das ist
für ein landwirt fast unmöglich ist
einen kredit zu bekommen und wenn es
ihnen doch gelingt müsste er mit zinsen
rechnen die über 40 prozent pro jahr
liegen können
[Musik]
kurz gesagt die kaffeebauern verfügen
über kein kapital um zu wachsen wenn sie
nicht wachsen können sie sich nicht
emanzipieren und wenn sie sich nicht
emanzipieren können sie keinen kredit
aufnehmen und das bringt uns zum dritten
großen problemen da die kleinbauern
keine komplexeren aktivitäten mit
höherer wertschöpfung puffern und
alleinstellungsmerkmalen entwickeln sind
sie den drei schwankungen auf den
internationalen kaffeemarkt völlig
ausgeliefert wenn es zum beispiel eine
auf breiter front gute ernte mit
reichlich überschüssen gibt kann es zu
einem preisverfall bis weit unter die
produktionskosten der landwirte kommen
schauen wir diesen schafft an und zu
sehen wie volatil der preispunkt kaffee
sein kann
und die im wahrsten sinne des wortes
preisfrage lautet daher wie zum teufel
sie diesen teufelskreis entkommen sollen
nun ihr können wir mindestens zwei
möglichkeiten finden die eine wäre den
zusammenschluss von kaffeebauern in
kooperativen und genossenschaften zu
fördern damit sie untereinander eine
größere einheit bilden die leichteren
zugang zu neuer technik besseren
handelsvereinbarungen uns finanzierung
hat sie könnten sich sogar gegenseitig
unterstützen weil es nötig eigentlich
eine sache die in europa schon vor 170
jahren zb durch friedrich wilhelm
raiffeisen flächendeckend eingeführt
wurde wieso also klappt das bis heute
nicht in lateinamerika nun weil es dort
schon viel grundlegenderen
zivilisatorischen fertigkeiten mangelt
für diese kleinbauern die in vielen
fällen weder lesen noch schreiben können
ist es nicht so einfach komplexe
organisationen zu entwickelt denn das
alles würde die beteiligung viele
produzenten auf einmal erfordern sie
alle müssten gleichzeitig einen
transformationsprozess in angriff nehmen
zunächst was ich selbst das problem eine
änderung ihrer traditionell wirtschafts
und arbeitsweise ist für die meisten von
ihnen schlicht und ergreifend eine sache
der unmöglichkeit dass sie sich
buchstäblich von tag zu tag ernähren von
der hand in den mund leben wenn sie an
einen händler verkaufen müssen die
weiter an ihn verkaufen um essen zu
können sie sind von ihrem händler ihren
abnehmer unglaublich stark abhängig denn
jeder einnahme ausfall könnte für sie
existenziell
darüber hinaus ist auch das große
problem nicht gelöst allein der prozess
der gründung von unternehmen oder
genossenschaften erfordert geld aber
gibt es wirklich noch nicht einmal den
versuch das ganze irgendwie anzupacken
doch im grunde schon allerdings haben
diese versuche einfach nicht die
notwendige reichweite und dimension um
mit der gesamten misere aufzuräumen
[Musik]
ich möchte euch das mal mit einem
beispiel veranschaulichen in kolumbien
gibt es den nationalen verband der
kaffeebauern der sogar schon im jahre
1927 gegründet wurde diese organisation
stellt über den sogenannten von der
regierung mattierten nationalen cup ev
den ankauf der gesamten produktion ihrer
mitglieder zu marktpreisen sicher und
verfügt über ein netzwerk von 36
genossenschaften und mehr als 500
einkaufs stellen im ganzen land dank
seiner größeren verhandlungsmacht auf
dem markt erzielt der verband wesentlich
höhere preise als ein kleinbauer wir
sprechen hier über 40 bis 50 prozent
höhere preise welche die
genossenschaften für ihre mitglieder
herausholen können und auf diese weise
mehr als 30 prozent der gesamten
kolumbianischen produktion absetzen das
problem ist jedoch dass dieses systems
oder seine mitglieder zwar sehr nützlich
ist sich aber in vielen anderen fällen
am ende als er unzureichendes instrument
erwiesen hat warum weil eben diese art
großer und bürokratische organisation
mit wenig kontakt zum markt irgendwann
an ihre grenzen stößt denn was der
verband tut ist ja eher garantiert
seinen mitgliedern den absatz ihrer
produktion und das wasser auch sonst
geht er kein stück in der
wertschöpfungskette weiter
und durch diese inflexibilität ist seine
gesamtabsatz kapazität eben begrenzt er
ist nicht in der lage mehr als 30
prozent der produktion auf dem markt zu
platzieren aber auch an dieser front tut
sich was der kolumbianische verband hat
nach 75 jahren den sprung gewagt und die
hohe an valdez kaffeekette ins leben
gerufen um die wertschöpfung der
kolumbianischen produzenten zu erhöhen
und sie haben bereits mehr als 120
niederlassungen auf der ganzen welt vor
allem weil es ist der echte
kolumbianischen rivale von starbucks
sicherlich verstehst du jetzt warum
diese marke den slogan verwendet el café
back tone und paris der café des ganzen
landes je mehr kaffee also bei cornwall
des staates bei starbucks getrunken wird
desto mehr kleinbauern kann der verband
unter seine fittiche nehmen und mit
fähren absatz verträgen versorgen
trotzdem der kampf gegen die globale
konkurrenz ist knallhart und es sieht
nicht danach aus dass rollen weil der
ist schnell genug wachsen kann um die
misere in kolumbien bald zu lösen also
schauen wir uns nach den zweiten
lösungsansatz den zugang zur
kollaborativen mikrokrediten einem
instrument das sich nach und nach immer
mehr durchsetzt
woraus bestehen diese mikrokredite nun
es handelt sich um kleine kredite wie
ohne einen bürgen aber viel niedrigeren
zinssätzen vergeben werden mit ihnen
kann ein kleinbauer mehr langt ein
traktor oder maschinen kaufen und auf
diese weise den teufelskreis zu
entkommen denn durch die investitionen
können sie ihre produktivität erhöhen
wachsen und ihren lebensstandard
verbessern und auf gutachten zinssätze
sind sie auch in der lage die kredite
zurückzahlen ohne in die sonst übliche
schuldenspirale zu geraten und das ist
der grund warum kollaborative
mikrokredite in und entwickelt ländern
so wichtig sind und zur zeit auch zum
glück stark wachsen du siehst also es
gibt unterschiedliche alternative
ansätze welche alle auf ihre art zur
reduzierung der armut von kaffeebauern
beitragen wollte es ist vor allem
wichtig sind miteinander zu kombinieren
denn nur so kommt man in einem so großen
komplexen und diversen markt wie die in
der kaffeewirtschaft ans ziel wir
sprechen ja nicht nur über den mehr als
25 millionen klein produzent punkt
sondern auch über die verbesserung der
lebensqualität von millionen
abermillionen weiterer menschen durch
diese art der förderung der lokalen
wirtschaft in ländlichen gebieten von
ländern wie mexiko brasilien kolumbien
und duras und guatemala und das leben
der kaffeebauern zu verbessern und diese
industrie zu einem motor des wohlstands
zu machen braucht es nicht weniger
marktwirtschaft sondern im gegenteil
mehr intelligente marktwirtschaftliche
lösung denn nur diese könnten nachhaltig
und langfristig helfen aber an dieser
stelle bist du ihn nicht mehr denn erst
mal einen schluck kaffee und beantwortet
folgende fragen im kommentarbereich hast
du jemals wenige halten und darüber
nachgedacht was hinter dem café steckt
den du jeden morgen trinkst was denkst
du wäre die beste formel um das leben
der millionen und abermillionen von
menschen die kaffee anbauen zu
verbessern alle deine meinung bitte wir
immer mit uns noch allen anderen im
kommentarbereich ich hoffe dass euch
dieses video gefallen hat falls ja gibt
uns bitte einen leicht teilt es mit
freunden mach s gut und bis bald
[Musik]